[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Batman video Warner
Brothers just dropped a whole bunch of
details we also have news about what's
going on in the larger Batman universe
and their future plans for the trilogy
itself and some of the really big
characters so we'll break it down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos will do
a new Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know what you want them to do with the
sequels so starting with number 5 if you
didn't see the news recently the rap
reported that because of the
overwhelming success of the Joker movie
with Joaquin Phoenix made over a billion
dollars secretly behind the scenes DC
movies were planning to do a new more
comic book accurate version of the Bane
character in his own DC Black Label
movie obviously it wouldn't be Tom
Hardy's version of Bane it'd be a
completely different actor they didn't
say who was going to direct it or write
it or which actor it was going to be
dave bautista was supposed to be in
James Gunn's Suicide Squad 2 movie but
had to decline because of scheduling
problems then later said he would love
to play the new version of Bane inside
Robert Pattinson Strohl gee that's why
you've been seeing all that fan art of
him as Bane he definitely looks like he
could pull the part off comic book Bane
even if they didn't use special effects
to make him look 8 feet tall when he's
tripping out on the venom serum if
you're really gonna go for a comic-book
accurate Bane but apparently since that
news broke a little while ago DC decided
not to do the full blown Bane solo movie
treatment DC Black Label mostly because
there are a billion more famous Batman
villains to do DC black label movies
about as you would expect
why wouldn't they go with their bigger
more popular characters first this all
makes sense in a second though because
number for the follow-up on that Bane
report is that DC isn't gonna do the
Bane movie also because they decided to
shuffle a new version of Bane into the
Robert Pattinson trilogy in one of the
sequels but just to be clear Bane is not
in the new Batman movie that's coming
out next year neither is the Joker
character and even though the Joker
movie made over a billion dollars and
changed the way you think about the
Joker character you think DC's first
thought would be to cross him over with
the Batman trilogy the director of The
Joker movie Todd Phillips was asked
about this throughout last year during
the Joker press to her and his answer
was always that he made the Joker movie
with the specific intent that it was his
own thing off in his own universe and
that was
part of the reason why Warner Brothers
let him do it rated R Robert Pattinson
was just cast as Batman I know this is a
totally different movie but but do you
see those two worlds merging together
anytime soon
no and even though the Joker ending
scene has a clear Batman origin moment
from the comics if you're taking Todd
Phillips at his word when they were
filming this he wasn't thinking to
himself this is Robert Pattinson 'he's
Batman being born right here in this
moment if you really start to pick it
apart too there are some age difference
issues between Joaquin Phoenix's Joker
and Robert Pattinson Batman the Joker
should usually only be no more than 10
to 15 years older than Batman in Joaquin
Phoenix is in his 50s even with D aging
technology the Joker movie was supposed
to take place in the early 80s so it's
just too much of a stretch and I'm not
on board with the theory that his Joker
inspired the real comic book Joker that
you see fighting Batman in all the
Batman comics I still think that he is
meant to be the Joker so number 3 right
now Matt Reeves has said that he doesn't
introduce a new version of the Joker
during the first Batman movie but they
will do him at some point during the
sequels he will come up he's just too
big of a character to completely swerve
on during this new trilogy most likely
with another actor and most likely after
any potential Joker sequel movie Todd
Phillips and Joaquin Phoenix's most
recent statements about doing a Joker
sequel are more along the lines of we're
not in any rush to do it but maybe we'll
do it someday which means if it does
happen it's probably gonna be bare
minimum four years before we see it
probably longer the more interesting
thing though within Warner Brothers is
their interest in replicating the
success of the Joker with other solo
movies for Batman villains the big
Batman villains so number two there was
also a recent report that Warner
Brothers intended to use Robert
Pattinson s new Batman trilogy to set up
potential spin-offs for the bigger
villain characters and there are some
recent actor comments that corroborate
this in the first new Batman movie next
year we know we're getting the Penguins
the Riddler Catwoman and carmine Falcone
it should go without saying even if you
Stan carmine Falcone as a character
they're probably not gonna give him a
solo movie but Colin Farrell who's
playing the penguin recently said that
he doesn't have much to do in this first
new Batman movie but he does get to have
a lot of fun with his scenes can we
say that you're playing the penguin in
the Batman movie yeah he just did yeah
yeah yeah
you a bull's-eye in the daredevil movie
and I thought you were fantastic in that
I really I really liked that
and now you're playing all demographic
thank you this cat no I don't know I'm a
I'm not being facetious but but the
penguin it surprises me that you are the
penguin cuz usually the penguin is a
short fat person yeah I have some time
to eat well you actually put a don't
know I'm still in the process of talking
to Matt Reeves who's the director who
wrote the script I wrote a really like
really beautiful dark moving script
really gorgeous you get the whole thing
already yeah yeah with a chain and you
know around my arm and cryogenically
frozen script it's all very right hush
but it's a really beautiful script that
he wrote he has a real love for it Matt
so we're still in the process of just
finishing designing the the aesthetic
Robert Pattinson is Batman and
Patterson's bottomland Jeffrey Wright
Danno is the Riddler yeah
Jeffrey writes in there zoe kravitz is
that woman yeah yeah really cool I love
the daredevil bull's eye shout out
during that interview the other funny
thing too you have to remember is that
both he now and Ben Affleck wound up in
the daredevil movie and then in Batman
movies but that along with the
statements that he's made since then
while they were actually working on the
film sort of corroborate the idea that
Warner Brothers is thinking about doing
a DC black label movie at some point in
the future with his penguin character
why would you cast someone as big as
Colin Farrell and Pam all that money for
such a huge event film the Batman movies
then barely use him in any scenes
probably because they want to lock him
down for future Batman movie spin-off
universe plans but would we even call a
Batman Cinematic Universe that existed
by itself self-contained the bat verse I
don't know just post your best theory
about what you would call that in the
comments but it's the same deal with the
Riddler the Catwoman
two-face once they debut a new version
of two-faced in the Batman movies
because number one there's also a new
rumor that says they're trying to get
Matthew McConaughey as their new to face
in the Batman sequels that doesn't mean
that they're gonna get him and he'll
sign a contract but it gives you an idea
for
how big they're going with their casting
aaron eckhart did a great job with his
version of two-face in the dark night
but I wouldn't exactly call him a huge
ælis actor he was mostly a supporting
role to Heath Ledger's Joker in that
movie one of the biggest complaints to
about superhero movies both Marvel and
DC all around is if they really do a
good job at developing all of their
villain characters especially films that
have multiple villains in them the Joker
movie with Joaquin Phoenix basically
solved that problem so you see all these
big Batman villains show up in the new
Robert Pattinson Batman trilogy but you
get the deep character study with each
of them in their potential solo movies
depending on how everything works out
and if things are successful if we're
talking about which order they would do
those solo movies and I'd rather see the
Riddler or the penguin movie first then
do the other one and then once they cast
their a new version of two-face do his
solo movie then after whatever the last
rubber pattinson Batman movie winds up
being then you do your Catwoman solo
movie because if you didn't see recently
the writer of the Batman movie
effectively confirmed that the movie is
based on the long Halloween comic book
story maybe not exactly like the comic
book story but definitely inspired by it
in there a couple sequel stories to the
long Halloween there's Batman and dark
victory which they could use as the plot
for the sequel to the Robert Pattinson
Batman movie then there's the Haunted
Knight and there's also a story called
Catwoman when in Rome which takes place
concurrently with one of those other
stories they could always use that is
the story for the Catwoman solo movie
though but you get the idea Warner
Brothers seems like it's trying to
construct a new cinematic universe
through this new Batman trilogy which i
think is kind of funny so just to be
clear Robert Pattinson --zz Batman isn't
meant to be connected to Justice League
or be a prequel to Ben Affleck's Batman
we do have the flash movie coming up
they're doing a version of flashpoint if
they want to use that to connect him to
Justice League if they really do want to
bring everything together for Justice
League 2 or whatever that sequel winds
up being they could always use a
flashpoint explanation but I think we're
so far away from a Justice League sequel
that it doesn't really matter but we
have the Snyder cut coming up but that's
not meant to be a sequel to the first
Justice League it's meant to replace the
original Justice League movie I've
already done a bunch of Justice League
Snyder cut videos so I'll link those at
the end of this but that's all
completely separate from what's going on
with the
Batman movies and Robert Pattinson so
there was some confusion about what's
going on with Ben Affleck coming back to
do Schneider cut stuff that's mostly to
do additional voiceover dialogue he's
not fully coming back as Batman but if
we get any other news about what's going
on with the Batman movie of course I'll
do a new video everyone is heading back
into production in a couple months this
summer so we should start to get more
news about it pretty soon everyone click
here for that Justice League Snyder cut
teaser trailer and click here for my new
spider-man 3 in venom 2 video thank you
so much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]